Dubey turtle is just more doom right
nope it's a sequel for sure picking up
where doom 2016 left off but if you
think you're just gonna run and gun your
way through hell on earth I got some
things to tell you if you play Doom 2016
you're probably familiar with having to
juggle between multiple weapons when
Amal runs low or when the situation
calls for one over the other you've also
had weapon upgrades for some handy
alternate fire attachments and we all
know about the nasty glory kills that
came in clutch two when you were low on
help or chopping up demons with a
chainsaw to get some ammo back that's
all there and remains a core part of the
ripping and tearing process for to
maternal bow wait there's more each
weapon attachment has its own upgrade
path to be even more effective you also
get a shoulder-mounted grenade launcher
which you can then swap to launch ice
bombs and freeze enemies in place then
there's a shoulder-mounted flamethrower
called the flame belch that burns demons
and makes them spit out armor shards
then you have the blood punch that sends
an AoE shockwave to do even more damage
through melee attacks some demons now
take on body damage letting you
dismember specific parts to stop them in
their tracks destroying an arachnid
Tron's tail gun or manky business arm
cannons and the easiest way to kill a
Cacodemons is to make them gobble up a
grenade doom slayer continues to be
superhuman with the return of runes
which act as upgrades that grant you
three dynamic abilities like an ultra
fast temporary speed boost after glory
kills slowing down time and midair or
magnetically dashing towards enemies for
easier glory kills praetor suit perks
are back as well
letting you boost resistances or enhance
basic capabilities within specific
categories all these systems are
necessary because if you're not pulling
out every stop in combat you're done son
doom eternal just throws so much at you
and you have to keep up with it combat
arena's seemed bigger to letting you put
that added mobility to use like swinging
cross monkey bars double jumping between
platforms and dashing out of the way of
enemy hordes and man the addition of
that double dash feels right at home for
navigating the chaos because when [ __ ]
hits the fan and demons start to spawn
into the combat arena you either get a
move on or die and I almost forgot about
the super shotguns hook shot
dumi turtle not only gives you all these
tools that have fun with but demands
that you master them in order to survive
I may have only scratched the surface to
exploring your hub area aka the fortress
of doom a fortress in space you'll see a
bunch of gear and upgrades locked behind
doors that open as you collect what are
called sentinel batteries throughout the
game we're not exactly sure what these
unlockables have in store but it's
exciting to know there's even more we
haven't seen if my three hours with the
game is any indication doom eternal is
going to challenge you in ways that make
doom feel new all over again it's one of
the big releases of the year
launching March 20th and we have you
covered so be sure to check out some
more in-depth impressions from our own
Michael Hardy and all our doom eternal
features on GameSpot